this is me at the age of five i wanted
to be a magician and so i tried to teach
myself card tricks at the age of eight i
wanted to become a writer and so i read
every single book i could get my hands
on at 14 i wanted to become a doctor and
so i started to read health manuals at
17 i want to become a physicist and so i
went to cern to learn physics at 20 i
wanted to become a medical artist and so
i taught myself to paint and draw at 25
i want to become a consultant so i
taught myself business and marketing you
basically get the idea ever since i can
remember i've been so anxious about the
fact that i can't do everything because
i really want to i want to learn it all
feel it all experience it all before
it's all gone and this very often leads
me to overcome it to things and then
struggle with maintaining my passion to
finishing them and seeing them to the
end somewhere between planning and
execution my desire for things often
gets lost and the way that i dream and
imagine them being does not match the
reality of doing them in real life and
as sexy and empowering as quitting has
sometimes been made to sound to me it
often is just not an option or it's not
the best option so as someone who has
gone through so many cycles of genuinely
wanting something only to feel that i
absolutely must immediately quit it
later i think i finally accepted that
there are things that i can specifically
do in order to maintain my passion for
doing something long-term because i
often can feel that my only two options
are to quit something or to painfully
stick through it which can be not fun
and lead to very mediocre performance in
my case but actually i've finally
accepted that there is such a thing as a
third option so today i've put together
a four-step framework that collects
everything i've found through both
science and my excruciatingly collected
personal experience about that third
space and increasing our passion and
motivation for sticking to things
long-term without wanting to quit them
let's get straight into it so the very
first step in stopping myself from
creating a task is perhaps a
counter-intuitive approach to motivation
which involves isolating all of the
object results that i am due from a task
that i'm supposed to do and completely
ignoring them in favor of skills instead
now the reason for this is that i've
realized two fairly obvious things the
first thing being that if i don't have
motivation to do a task i am very very
likely going to want to quit this task
very soon and the second thing that i
realize is that motivation is always
there there are things for my life for
which i have endless sources of
motivation and there are things for my
life which at the same time i have no
motivation at all so the issue isn't
that i'm lacking energy or motivation as
a person it's just i believe that i am
attaching these sources of motivation to
the wrong thing within a task that just
cannot fuel that motivation and
therefore it never grows for that
specific task and i generally think that
tying my source of motivation to any
sort of object result for a task be that
something good or bad something i'm
interested or not interested in is
always a bad long-term strategy because
it guarantees that the motivation will
at some point disappear while tying this
motivation to skills fuels it
consistently long term let me explain
exactly what i mean so as an example
here i'm going to use a long-term
project that i would have which is for
example to write an essay for university
and i hate writing essays about child
referral pathways for example and for
any sort of task or project there are
going to be results that i'm due to get
through this task and these can all be
divided into two categories things that
i'm interested in and things that i am
not interested in and i'll explain why
in the long term both should be ignored
the easy one let's say that the result
of the essay is what my professor tells
me that the better you perform at this
essay the better grades you will get and
therefore the better you will be in the
workplace i don't care about this
because it's not true one i've been in
the workplace and no one cares about
your grades they care about your
performance and secondly i've been in
formal education for over 20 years at
this point i couldn't care less about
grades so this sort of result tied to a
boring task is just never going to give
me motivation because i don't care for
the task i don't care for the results
there's nothing there but the other
thing that i used to depend on in the
past but is a mistake in my opinion is
depending on things that i temporarily
or always care about because they still
will not fuel my motivation for example
the results of doing the essay is that
one i pass my medical school and two
that i become a doctor and even though
these seem like strong things they're
not enough to fuel motivation in the
long term because depending on how bad
the task is and how much i hate doing it
then i'm going to start to get creative
about different ways to get the same
results because
i'm not that stupid so i might think
well you know i know i need to do this
essay to pass medical school but it's
really boring i don't want to do it now
i've never failed anything and i could
technically get away with failing this
so i have no motivation to do it and i
don't want to do it or then depending on
how difficult multiple projects are i
start thinking do i really need to be a
doctor do i actually need to graduate
maybe i could do other things to help
people and make money is this actually
necessary so because these thoughts are
running in the back of my mind there's
no way that i'm going to find motivation
in these results in the long term and so
my proposal is that we completely ignore
any sort of object results so first i'll
find them all what people have told me
to care about what i think i care about
any sort of result i would get from
doing the task and i just scrub it and
forget about it and this is where things
become interesting what i do instead is
i take the task and i break it down into
all of its component skills and i will
go crazy with this every single small
thing that is involved in this task so i
think for example writing this essay
will make me a better writer a better
speaker a better communicator it will
increase my typing speed potentially it
will help me structure arguments better
it will help me understand children more
it will help me understand how these
systems and hospitals work it might help
me understand the english law system it
might help me understand how to
communicate with younger people it might
help me understand and empathize with
parents and different sort of patients
in the hospital so there's a bunch of
skills here that are involved in this
task and then what i'm going to do is
i'm going to cross-reference this with
my set of skills and values and i have
an exercise for this in the description
in detail if you're interested in trying
this out but i'll try and think of what
are the core skills and values in my
life and this is quite easy to come up
with so for example i think i want to
become a good parent one day i want to
be um a good friend i want to be a good
communicator with people i want to
understand myself and my emotions better
and i can start then cross-referencing
these things directly or in creative
ways so for example writing an essay and
actually really trying hard to structure
my arguments properly will mean that i
will have better insight into how my
thoughts work and how to structure and
communicate things which then leads to
these skills and i can also think that
thinking about where things go wrong
with children in the healthcare system
can then potentially help me understand
how proper communication with children
is done and maybe that makes me a better
parent in the future or then i can think
that while communicating with things
better in an essay will make me express
myself and my thoughts and feelings
better and therefore will make me a
better friend etc etc i try to go for
the crazy ones here just so i can make a
point of there are so many connections
that can be done but by doing this thing
and therefore reframing this task in a
completely different manner where i
don't care that it's an essay i don't
care if it's even tied with medical
school what i care about is that it is a
vehicle for me to improve these skills
which are things that fuel my motivation
a lot more because results are quite
temporary and depending on how zen i am
i tend to not care about the fact that i
will become a doctor one day or that i
will become successful one day or that i
want to do these things but i do care a
lot more about things that i value like
being a better person and being more
helpful to other people and
communicating better and being more
empathetic and loving these are things
that i have endless sources of
motivation for and therefore tying a
task no matter how boring to these sort
of skills makes this task then much more
interesting and it fuels a perspective
and a shift in my mind on the way that i
approach this task that actually leads
me to so much better performance in them
because even though realistically
nothing has changed on the surface i
still need to just sit down and type in
front of my computer the marking
criteria have not become easier no one's
done any sort of work for me the task is
just as boring in terms of what i have
to write but because i have this
perspective shift because i'm genuinely
invested and motivated for certain
aspects or angles of this essay no
matter how tangential that often is just
enough for me to get into doing this
task with a whole lot of motivation and
therefore avoid this desire to quit it
so this is what i do for many different
tasks and projects in my life i have
this list of skills really well broken
down so things that i want to do
everything that i see and i approach in
my life i kind of try to see what skills
are involved in it cross-reference them
with things that i value and then use
the task that i need to do and i don't
want to do as just a vehicle of
improving myself instead of focusing on
the thing and the things that people
tell me to care about like making more
money and passing exams and getting
numbers here and there this tends to be
very helpful for me i know it sounds
quite selfish and self-focused but it
really really helps in fueling
motivation for things that i would
otherwise be completely unable to find
so my second tool involves not quitting
a task through preserving motivation and
keeping an eye on the progress that i am
making and the strategies to avoid not
doing things that don't move the needle
that's a mouthful let me try and break
it down so progress has been identified
to be a major source of motivation and
this is both a positive and a very
dangerous thing because especially in
the cases where we are actually doing
work but we are not seeing any results
or not seeing the results that progress
that we want we can be in a place where
it's very very easy to have no
motivation and to absolutely want to
quit something and therefore i think
very often especially me in my life i
have set myself up for failure or at
least made things so much harder for me
to do and not giving myself a proper
shot at something that i could have
potentially been good at and i
eventually ended up quitting because i
have not been strategic about it in the
beginning this tool is called always
meet your heroes i'm going to use an
example of youtubers here when i first
started my youtube channel and
especially before starting it i thought
that what it took to become a very
successful youtuber in terms of skills
for educational youtube would be to be
quite confident to be quite charismatic
to be very funny and interesting and a
very super passionate and extroverted
person when having met a lot of
youtubers with a few million subscribers
at this point and seeing how they are in
person is very very different to how i
imagined them to be and actually the
skills that they were scoring very
highly on were neuroticism obsession
introversion ability to sit down and
tweak things on their computers for days
and days and so i realized that they
were very very different to what i
thought that they would be in person and
this kind of led me to the realization
in many different times in my life
actually that the skills that i think
that are important to succeed in a
certain task or domain are very often
very different to the ones that are
actually necessary and therefore when i
meet people that are my heroes or people
who are very successful in these fields
they end up being very confusing and a
very disappointing in a way experience
when i realized that they're so
different because i thought that it
would mean that you need to be so funny
to be successful at this when actually
what you need is to be kind of
neurotically obsessed at things which is
a completely different set of skills and
so i think meeting your heroes is a
perspective for thinking wait what is
actually necessary to succeed at this
task and what are the skills that
genuinely move the needle because we
don't want to be quote very long term in
a task that we don't enjoy doing things
that don't move the needle because then
we're wasting energy not making progress
and we are really putting our motivation
at risk so especially with tasks that i
already want to quit and tasks that i
know i'm not likely to enjoy a lot i
very quickly in the beginning will make
an assessment of what is going to move
the needle and that doesn't mean that i
only do the painful work that i don't
enjoy but it does mean that i never
completely ignore the skills and the
things that are absolutely essential for
this task because basically overnight
and with the same amount of work i can
get so much better results at something
if i focus on the things that actually
matter for it rather than what i feel
like doing or approaching things not
strategically and this has been such a
huge change for me because i did this
for the longest time and absolutely
everything i focused on the wrong things
so in any sort of serious task
especially when we are wanting to quit
it does well to us to look at the people
who are performing best and if possible
communicate with them or just otherwise
really kind of think about the task
critically and realize what are the
things that are actually the most
important here and start focusing on
those for a while we are likely then to
see results which are much much better
and with progress comes increased
motivation which then keeps our desire
to quit at bay and we are doing much
better at this task without wanting to
leave it my third tool is a very
elizabeth specific one so if you don't
resonate to my way of thinking you might
want to skip to the fourth one because
this might not be relevant but this is
basically a visual perspective that i
keep in mind when i am approaching any
sort of task that i am taking and
actually when i'm approaching anything
in my life in order to maintain
consistent motivation for long periods
of time i can be quite a passionate and
obsessive person which has its good
sides but also has a lot of downsides so
on the positive end it means that i
learn things super fast i get very very
involved and i get super passionate and
i can do work with very very good
results for some periods of time when
i'm invested in something but on the
negative side it means that i am very
often put in the weeds and i completely
lose perspective and i think i'm on a
path that if i'm starting to not enjoy i
feel completely trapped and desperate
and as though i have no solutions and i
can very quickly spiral into a lot of
anxiety around that task in general what
i do here is something that i call
strategic detachment and this is
basically where i'm keeping my
attachment and my passion in terms of
the motivation and how intensely i
perform at a task but i'm becoming quite
detached intentionally from my
associations with the tasks and my
identity and trying to keep an overall
perspective so visually the way that i
see this is that very often for many
different tasks or projects and they can
be big ones or small ones like i'm going
to medical school i feel like i'm on
this path of becoming a doctor and if i
take upon a task or responsibility i
feel like i'm on the path of completing
it and even if i read a book sometimes
as i've started i might see myself as
being on the path of finishing this book
and if i don't enjoy this thing i feel
trapped and very very strongly more and
more as i want to completely escape when
quitting is not probably the best
solution here the solution is changing
my perspective on everything so the way
that i see things now is that i am never
on the path of any sort of task that i
need to do and this might sound
grandiose so i apologize but i am on my
path and my skills path so everything
that i'm moving towards is comprised
just of me my future and the skills that
i want to keep on it and everything that
i do is just a vehicle to improve these
skills and myself and it's not the
actual path that i'm on so i'm not
becoming a doctor in the sense that i'm
on the path of doing that i'm becoming
elizabeth and being a doctor is just a
way for me to spend my time learning
about the human body and helping people
and kind of getting to get closer to
people and do things that i enjoy it's
just a vehicle for me to get to this
goal and when i start a book or when i
start a youtube channel i recognize that
all of these things are temporary i'm
probably going to leave youtube soon and
all of these different stuff are
happening these are just ways for me to
improve skills that i care about
communication skills connection skills
empathy skills how i want to spend my
time and my life is my perspective on
these things and i realize that this
feels like a bit of a selfish approach
and practically it does not change
things if anything it's helped me stop
quitting so many things by just
realizing i'm not trapped here this is
just something that i'm doing in order
to get somewhere else and so i know this
is a bit of a wishy-washy one but if we
can i would genuinely strongly recommend
doing the exercise of finding your
skills and the things that you value and
focusing on them and yourself and the
task and kind of ignoring the tasks that
you do and not feeling that you're
sucked into them that can help you not
want to quit them in the long term
because you realize that you're valuing
them only for the things that they are
and they are more temporary and fleeting
and we are never genuinely stuck
somewhere at least in our minds we can
always not be stuck somewhere which i
find to be insanely liberating lastly i
think that a strong trigger to want to
quit something for me is performing
badly at it consistently or not
progressing in this thing i realized
that actually there's a perspective that
i can change in order to switch this up
very very fast and for me that's called
instinct building so basically i think
that instincts are something that are
massively underrated instinct is that
ability that we can't put into words for
why we know something but we actually
know that that is the case so for
example when i'm in hospital i see that
nurses instinctively know when a patient
is acutely unwell even though they can't
tell us or me specifically why that is
they just know and that's an instinct of
having seen this thing very many times
sometimes i know that it's a good or bad
time for me to do things or what to do
even without being able to explain why
that's the case i just simply know it
because i have enough experience with
myself so i think that when i am not
progressing and i'm feeling like
quitting telling myself that actually
what's happening right now is that if i
just become a bit more intentional and i
realize what's happening this is not
futile what i'm doing is increasing my
instinct in the skills that i value in
that task and instinct is so so so
invaluable the reason for that is you
can only get it through painful
experience no one can pay to get your
instinct from you they can pay to get
you a response but they can't get it we
can only accrue instinct for ourselves
no one can take it away from us and no
one can give it to us and so it is an
absolutely invaluable skill i truly
believe that any long-term intentional
time i spent on a task is making me an
expert at that task and so
intentionality is something that i focus
on a lot i try to create short feedback
loops for everything that i do whenever
i'm doing a task even if it's completely
boring or i'm performing badly at it i
try to think how every small thing i do
leads to a response i try to be
intentional about this when i do things
this way this ends up when i do things
that way this ends up happening and i
see these feedback loops again and again
mistakes are a hugely positive thing to
frame in this way and seeing as this
growing my instinct and then in the
future investing in me becoming either
better at this task or at the skills
that this task involves i'm basically
being an expert in an extra field in my
life and the other better thing here is
that when we build instinct and
intuition at a task what we're doing is
fueling a source of endless motivation
and joy because we really really like to
do things that we can do instinctively
because they give us this sort of like
dopamine pleasure of going oh i'm in the
flow i understand what's happening i'm
feeling really really good and therefore
i'm investing in the future and not
wanting to quit other tasks and making
all other tasks that i do kind of easier
through increasing my intuition in the
skills that i care about and so the
skills i mentioned earlier i keep in
mind as being the things that i want to
become better at instinctively and
therefore because i then see all future
tasks that i do as a vehicle of
improving these skills i'm in this
positive loop of the older i get the
more i work the less i want to quit
things the more i can make myself
interested in things easier and the
better everything becomes and it just
becomes this positive cycle of
improvement which is so so so awesome
and it feels absolutely amazing i think
quite ironically this instinctual thing
is what i'm trying to do with this video
where i'm trying to break down every way
that i see things in my life and trying
to transfer that into a structure and a
format and a template that can hopefully
help other people too every framework
that i've said in this video i've broken
down in a lot more detail with guiding
questions in a guide below that also has
this template of being able to start
projects and then fill them in with
these tools and then watch your progress
with them there's no gatekeeping of
information or secrets in that template
it's basically everything that i've said
in much more detail and structured with
a kind of project list and a way to
apply this again and again so if you
want to check that out it will be linked
in my description otherwise thank you so
much for spending this time with me i
hope you have a wonderful rest of the
day become yourself and others and don't
believe everything you think thanks bye